يمكن أن أشعر بأن المخاط
يتراكم في رئتي مثل ملايين الأمريكيين الآخرين الذين
تبلغ أعمارهم 26 عامًا ، وقد ثبتت إصابة كلاي باينجتون
بفيروس covid19 بعد
التجمع مع الأصدقاء والعائلة
خلال العطلات عندما جاء السعال ، مما أدى
بالتأكيد إلى إرسال البيض إلى الجسم.
قلقة للغاية
بشأن مدى مرضك كنت
قلقة جدًا ، لقد
رأيت الكثير من القصص حول كيفية
تدهور صحة الناس
بسرعة كبيرة كما تعلم في غضون أيام ،
أعلم أنني كنت بدينة
فقط نوعًا ما قلقتني على الرغم من
تعزيز الطين الطيني  من بين 35 شخصًا وضعوه في
خطر أكبر ، لذلك وصفه طبيب كلاي
باكس
مضاد فيروسات ثبت أنه
يقلل من دخول المستشفى بنسبة 90 في
المائة تقريبًا بين أولئك المعرضين لخطر
الإصابة بمرض شديد ، فهم يغيرون قواعد
اللعبة ولديهم القدرة على
تغيير التأثير بشكل كبير  من covet 19. paxlovid
عبارة عن مزيج من الحبوب التي تؤخذ عن طريق الفم والتي تعمل
عن طريق التدخل في قدرة الفيروس
على التكاثر بناءً على الفعالية العالية لـ pax
lovid  20 مليون دورة تم شراؤها من
قبل إدارة بايدن يمكن
أن تمنع في النهاية أكثر من مليون
دخول إلى المستشفى بناءً على
حسابات سي إن إن
ولكن المشكلة هي أن غالبية
هذه الجرعات لن تصل لأشهر
، ولا يكاد يوجد أي من حزم حبوب منع الحمل هذه
حول دكتور إيريك توبيل مسؤول تنفيذي  نائب
الرئيس للبحث في scripps في سان
دييغو ، يعتقد أن إدارة بايدن كان
ينبغي أن تستثمر في
paxlovid قبل أشهر لو كان لدينا
مئات الملايين من عبوات
paxilvid في الوقت الحالي ،
فسنكون قادرين بشكل أفضل على
مقاومة omicron قبل عدة أشهر
تمت الموافقة على اللقاحات ، حيث كانت هناك
استثمارات معرضة للخطر تم إجراؤها على العديد من الرهانات
على لقاحات مختلفة وأنت
تعلم أن هذه المقامرة
كانت نفس أنواع المقامرة التي تم إجراؤها
على العلاجات ، حقيقة أن هذا
كان أول
دواء تم تصميمه خصيصًا ضد
هذا الفيروس
أعتقد أنه كان يستحق التجربة ، فقد كان
يستحق الاستثمار فيه ولكن لم يكن هناك
حتى الآن سوى 160  تم تقديم 000 1 دورة تدريبية في
جميع أنحاء البلاد
ومع وجود عدد أكبر من الأشخاص الموجودين حاليًا في المستشفى
مع Covet 19 أكثر من أي وقت آخر
خلال الوباء ، فإن هذه
الحبوب ستكون متوفرة قريبًا وستحتاج
إلى تقنين وربما يكون من الصعب ترك
الأطباء مثل Sharisha dan بالفعل في
الجامعة  في مركز هاربورفيو الطبي في واشنطن
مع بعض القرارات الصعبة ،
فإننا نستخدم هذه الأدوية
بحكمة
ونمنحها حقًا للأشخاص الذين
سيستفيدون أكثر من هذه العلاجات إذا
فتحناها أمام الأفراد الذين تم تطعيمهم ،
فلن يكون لدينا علاج كافٍ
إذا حصل عليها الشخص المُلقح  مقابل
غير الملقحين أو يجب أن يكون فقط لغير
الملقحين ، أعني أنه سيثير
جميع أنواع الأسئلة الأخلاقية والطبية ، حيث
أن التوافر محدود للغاية
وسيصبح المزيد من الأشخاص غير المحصنين
في حاجة
إلى المعاهد الوطنية للإرشاد الصحي.
علاج
الأشخاص الأكثر عرضة للخطر
والمرضى الذين يعانون من نقص المناعة وكبار السن  قد لا يحتاج
العديد من الأشخاص غير الملقحين
لهذا العلاج إلى هذا العلاج
للتعافي
من مرض كوفيد 19 وخاصة إذا تم تطعيمك معززًا ،
فهناك علاجات أخرى متاحة ولكن
ريمدزافير مضاد للفيروسات ، وبالتالي فإن
الأجسام المضادة وحيدة النسيلة تتطلب
حقنًا ومانوبيرافير
حبوب منع الحمل الأخرى التي يتم تناولها عن طريق الفم هي الخيار الأخير الذي
لا يوصى به بأي منها مثل paxlovid
بالأمس لم يكن البرد أسوأ من ذلك ، واليوم
أشعر بأن الطين أفضل كثيرًا كان أحد
القلائل المحظوظين الذين حصلوا على الراحة الجسدية
وكذلك الراحة النفسية  من الدواء
بمجرد أن تكون
مريضًا وأنت تعلم
أنك تشعر بأن الأعراض
وأنك تشبه نوعًا ما ، يا
إلهي ، إن هذا سيزداد سوءًا ،
لذا
فقد ساعد هذا النوع من الأدوية في التخفيف  هذا
التوتر والقلق
الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا سي إن إن التقارير